(air whooshing)
(inspirational spacey music)
- Today we're gonna look at a demo
of our project Feature Fields
for Robotic Manipulation.
- The purpose of this project
is to give these robots
the ability to understand the world in 3D.
- [William] We're going to get the robot
to grasp these objects on the table
using open-ended language.
So what the robot's doing now,
is it's picked up this camera
mounted on a selfie stick
and it's going to take
50 RGB images of a scene.
What this gives us is a holistic
understanding of the entire scene.
- [Ge] So neural radiance field is a way
to turn these images into
a 3D model of the scene
that can render hyper
photorealistic renders of the scene.
- And in addition to just
the neural radiance fields,
we also train a 3D feature field.
And this 3D feature field lifts features
from 2D Vision foundation models,
which are trained on
internet scale data sets
into a 3D feature representation.
- [Ge] The robot hasn't seen these objects
before during training.
In fact, the robot doesn't even know
which object we're gonna ask
it to pick up until we tell it
so this is what makes
this task open-ended.
- Here we've exported a
point cloud of the scene
using the neural radiance
field we just trained.
As you can see, we can go from 2D images
to this 3D representation.
So now let's ask the robot
to grasp specific objects via language.
Here you can see the grasps
overlaid on top of that point cloud.
And now we can ask the
robot to find a motion plan
to execute on the robot.
Here's a visualization of what
we expect the robot to do,
which is pick up Baymax
and can see the robot's
finding a path to grasp Baymax,
pick it, and then place it into the bin
on the other side of the table.
Now let's see the robot
planning to grasp the bowl,
and the important thing is that the robot
has never seen how to grasp a bowl before.
It's going to pick it and
then place it into the bin.
- [Ge] Now we're gonna test if the robot
can pick up the spatula.
The spatula's a pretty difficult object
because it's held as a very awkward angle
and it's also very thin,
it's difficult to grasp.
So what you just saw,
is the robot being able to
pick up all of these objects
despite that it has never
seen these objects before.
- And in the future, we really want
to make this representation more real-time
so we can enable robots
to do more dynamic tasks
in the household, in the factory,
and in manufacturing environments.